は）こんにちははじめしゃちょーと
シ）どうもFischer’sシルクです
は）ンダホさんを今までどうやって起こしてきましたか，逆に
シ）揺さぶっても基本起きないんで
シ）一応伝説持ってて，着陸飛行機がして
キャビンアテンダントさんが
起こしにかかったんですけど起きな過ぎて肩もって
人人人人人人人人人
＜お客様～～！！＞
ＹＹＹＹＹＹＹＹＹ
(笑)
は）何か動画とかでも結構見たんですけどンダホがガチで起きないという情報聞いたんですけども
ちょっとある手段でここは起こしてあげましょう
シ）あ～あ（なるほど）
それはちょっと僕的にも役立つ
は）ちょっとこれなら行けんじゃないかというものを持ってきまして
シ）おまけに大っ嫌いです電気
は)電気が嫌いなの？
は）きた～
は)1個じゃなくてな、ンダホ用にたくさん・・・
（カランドタン）
は）一応たくさんあると危ないと思ったから
事前に僕100か所体につけてテストでやってあるんで
は）（は～ははは）(笑)
は）ちょっと死にかけたぐらいだったんで
シ）（ふふっ）(笑)
（カタン）
は）影響はないと思われます
シ）そうっすねそうっすね
は）試しにちょっとシルクさんでやってみましょう
シ）はい、っへっ！？
シ）いやマジじゃ…
シ）いやこれやるの初めてっすね、やんの
は）そんなにねぇ、めちゃくちゃ強いってわけでもないんですけど 10段階ありまして
は）行きますね
は）これで１
シ）あ、わかんないっすね
は）２
シ）あっ！
は）345678910！
シ）あ、痛って！
は）ｗｗｗ
は）凄い凄いｗｗ
シ）止めて止めて止めて
は）どうですか
シ）こんな揺れんすね
は）そうそうそう！
は）だからこれ１００ケ所つけたとき
は）もうｗｗｗ
シ）ｗｗｗ
シ）行けそうっすね
は）いやでも
は）もう良い情報を頂いた
は）そもそも電気苦手でしょ？　シ）苦手です
は）で、これを
は）5個準備したんで
は）合計20ヶ所これが流れるんで
は）だからこれで起きれればいいかなという
シ）起きますねこれ
は）では早速、起こしていきましょう
は）ｗｗ
は）やろやろやろ！
シ・は）ｗｗｗ
は）肩いきたい
シ）肩いきたいですか？
シ）ｗｗｗ
は）無理無理無理！
は）肩はダメだ
シ）怖ぇ～コイツ
は）はい！という訳で
は）全20ヶ所に
は）電撃が流れるようになったので
は）一気に！　シ）はい
は）レベルＭＡＸにｗｗ　シ）ｗｗｗ
は）レベル10まで！一気に上げようと思います
は）これで起きたら
は）画期的だ…でしょ？
は）ビンタとかじゃない、純粋にマッサージで！
シ）そうですね
は）マッサージで起きるとしたら彼ももう…
は）是非是非、今後のンダホのね
シ）そうですね　は）早起きを願って
は）流していきますっ！
（ｶﾁｶﾁｶﾁ…）
は）はい
シ）ｗｗ
シ・は）ｗｗｗｗｗｗｗ
ン）んん…
ン）（ﾊﾟﾝｯ）
は）ｳﾜｯ
ン）痛い痛い…
は）ｳﾜｰｯ
は）痛ーっ！！！
（エンディング）
シ）ｗｗｗｗ
は）（ﾊﾞｺﾝｯ）
は）起きないんかい
シ）ｗｗ
は）起きないじゃん！
シ）起きないｗ　は）起きないじゃんｗｗ
は）起きないの？　シ）あれ？
シ）おーい？
は）ンダホ痛かったの？
ン）…………
は）ンダホ痛かった？
は）痛かった？
ン）…………
は）ダメだこりゃｗ
シ）ｗｗｗｗ